in chemistry there's a very valuable
concept called specific heat and the
specific heat is particular to a given
substance so every substance has a
different specific heat and it's defined
as the amount of heat the amount of heat
energy needed to raise one gram of a
substance one degree celsius sometimes
the definition might say to raise a
given mass of a substance one degree
celsius but i'm just being a little bit
more a little bit more particular one
gram of a substance one degree celsius
so it's telling us is well how much
energy do i have to put into something
to heat it up so for example for example
water
water if i want to raise that one degree
celsius so if i want to raise that one
degree celsius i would have to put in i
would have to put in a certain amount of
i would have to put in a certain amount
of heat which would be different than
say if i had sand let's say this is
let's say this is sand
this is sand right i have trouble
picking colors
so this is sand right over here i can do
a better job of drawing sand so this is
sand right over here
if i want to raise that
one degree celsius i would need a
different amount and it actually turns
out that i need less heat i need less
heat to raise the sand one degree
celsius than i need to raise the
temperature of the water or one gram of
the water one degree celsius so let's
say this is a gram of water and this is
a gram of sand i'm going to need more
heat here to raise this one degree
celsius than to raise that and that's
because water has a higher specific heat
so higher
higher relatively higher specific heat
specific
heat
and sand or at least relative to water
has a lower specific heat
lower specific heat so two ways you
could think about it
let me write this lower lower specific
specific
heat
two ways to think about it if you want
to raise one gram of each of them one
degree celsius you're going to have to
put more energy into the water than
you're going to have to put into the
sand or the other way around if you put
the same amount of energy into both
you're going to raise the temperature of
the sand a lot more than you would raise
the temperature of the water
and water actually its specific heat has
a special name and this is a name that
you have seen before the specific heat
of water is called the calorie
specific
specific
heat
of water
is called
the calorie and you have seen this word
before when you've when you've wanted to
cut calories when you've looked at the
back of nutritional labels on on on food
now there's one clarification the
calorie that people talk about when
they're talking about nutritional labels
or how many calories are actually in
food that's actually kilocalories so if
you see
if someone hands you a let's say a bowl
of ice cream let me draw a bowl of ice
cream here so if someone hands you a
bowl of ice cream right over here and
they tell you that this is 500 calories
so let me write that down this is 500
calories if we're thinking of it in
terms of specific heat it's actually 500
kilocalories
500 kilo
kilo
calories
so there's a couple of ways that you
could think about 500 kilocalories you
could think about it as this is this
this ice cream has enough energy to
raise
to raise 500
500 kilograms of water
water 1 degrees celsius you could also
view it as the amount well actually if
you want to think of it in more human
terms most humans or roughly grown
people are between say 50 kilograms or
60 70 kilograms roughly over there so
you could say 50 kilograms of water
actually a grown male might be composed
of about 50 kilograms of water there's
obviously other things that make up
their weight i'm just
approximating 50 gram 50 kilograms of
water
and we're raising it one degree celsius
in the top case but in this case you
would raise it 10
you would raise it 10 degrees celsius
and that's actually happening in our
body your body heat is actually caused
partially your the energy from food some
of it is to process your movement and
the different functions of your muscles
and the brain and all the things your
body does and some of it it just is just
producing heat sometimes as a byproduct
of that movement and sometimes frankly
just for the sake of producing heat so
500 500 calories that you see on a food
label that's really 500 kilocalories and
that's the that's enough energy to raise
500 000 grams of water remember 500
kilograms 500 000 grams of water 1
degree celsius or 50 000 grams of water
10 degrees celsius
but anyway water has a special name it's
a calorie it's neat to be able to
connect it to what we're eating and to
think about what a calorie actually
means or to a killer calorie actually
means but this this this notion that
water has a higher relative specific
heat to say things like land actually
has huge impacts on our climate and it's
actually one of the reasons why it's
often nice to live near the coast
because let me draw let me draw a
coastline right over here
so this is
actually i'll draw it from i'll draw it
from above
so that's the coastline this is land
let's just say it's made up of sand for
the sake of argument and other things
and this is water
and let's think about it first let's
think about it in the summer let's think
about in the summer
when it is hot and you think about just
a sunny a sunny day
so in the summer when things are hot so
you have the sun
you have the sun right over here and
it's radiating energy and obviously the
air also has is is also
warming up the things that it comes in
touch with
but you're having
at least at the coastline the air is
roughly the same temperature over both
and although there will be some
variation and they're getting the same
amount of sunlight but since water has a
higher specific heat that heat is going
to what is going to warm up water less
so this is going to get less hot let me
write it over here this is going to get
less hot
less hot
and the land is going to get more hot
more hot
more hot and that's why when you're in
the coastline the air is also affected
by what's in touch with it's going to be
in touch with this less hot water and so
is the air especially if it's coming
from the ocean if the air is going in
this direction then if you're at the
coast you're going to get probably a
cooler breeze and if you're more inland
over here if you're more inland over
here it's probably going to be a lot the
air is going to be hotter so this is
going to be hotter air if you're inland
and it's less hot air if you're at the
coastline because the air is being
cooled down to some degree it's not
being warmed up as much by the water now
you have the opposite effect if you
think about the coldest times of the
year if you think about the middle of
the night in the winter so let me draw
that
so
if you think about night time in the
winter when everything is cooling down
when everything is cooling down once you
have your coastline
well now they're both the land over here
and the water they're going to be
radiating heat
and the water is going to be radiating
heat there's no other sources of heat
there's radiating heat into the air but
if they if they radiate roughly the same
amount of heat the land is going to drop
in temperature much much more so it's
going to get colder here so the land is
going to get colder and the water is
going to get less cold
because it works in both directions more
energy goes in the water the temperature
changes less and it could also radiate
the same amount of heat but also lose a
less
it would also lose less temperature so
in the winter and really cold times of
the year well the air above the water
when it comes to touch with the water is
going to be less cold than the air above
the land because the water is less cold
than land and so it's nice to live near
the water it's going to be less cold in
the coastal areas than it would be if
you're further inland and this this
phenomenon this is frankly anywhere
where you might see water but it's it's
very pronounced where i live i live in
the san francisco bay area
and if you live you literally have this
you have the pacific ocean let me draw
that
you have
the pacific
ocean here
you have a
ocean
right over here and you have
the san francisco bay that looks
something like that you have your golden
gate bridge is right over here for
anyone who is curious this is san
francisco right up here i actually live
right
right about there and you see it if you
if you hang out in the summer in the
middle of the day in the coastline it
could be
maybe 10 10 degrees even 20 degrees
cooler than if you are well inland over
here so it has very a profound impact on
weather patterns so the last thing you
might be wondering is well why does
water have such a high specific heat
well that goes back to our good old
friend the hydrogen bond
because if you're talking about a solid
substance if you're talking about a
solid substance and i'll just draw a
generic solid substance
so a solid substance right over here i
don't know what this is let's say it's
in some type of
structure that looks something like this
as it gets energy as it gets as it gets
heat energy the heat energy just
increases the kinetic energy of the
actual particles it actually just makes
them vibrate more
makes them vibrate in place more and
that's actually what temperature is it's
really average kinetic energy when you
touch something like oh that's hot it's
really because those things are just
vibrating rear super super super super
fast so it's going to make these things
vibrate more almost in place especially
if you're thinking about something that
is a solid while in the case of water
sure when you get more energy it's going
to make the water molecules move around
faster vibrate more have more kinetic
energy but in order to have more kinetic
energy they're going to have to overcome
this kind of creation and and and and
and breaking up of the hydrogen bonds
you can almost imagine the friction of a
hydrogen bond bond you can imagine if if
this water molecule wants to move in
this direction it has to break this
hydrogen bond it's going to form another
hydrogen bond it's got to break that and
so it needs energy to keep breaking and
rem and or at least breaking those
hydrogen bonds overcoming the friction
of those hydrogen bonds and i'll use
i'll use the friction in quotes because
it's well actually all friction is
actually some type of of atomic force
that's occurring at a at a microscopic
level but it's having to overcome that
and so some of this heat energy is
actually used to overcome that as
opposed to increasing the actual kinetic
energy of the individual molecules or
making them vibrate or whatever to
actually increase their temperature and
this is why water is able to store more
heat and why it has a higher specific
specific
heat